what's up guys welcome back to an
episode of chappelle's world and my
guest today
mr zacharias holmes also known as zac
ass yeah and one of the newest members
of the jackass crew
how you doing dog good good good good
good thanks for having me of course man
it's so funny i didn't even i don't even
think you made any kind of announcements
that until like
they had like you know committed to
doing jack or like we're putting out the
trailers yeah uh of doing jackass i
don't even know you're gonna be on it
but i have been following you for a
minute yeah obviously because i've you
know
seen a lot of your stuff
you're a crazy [ __ ]
and it is
you know i guess i'm just so intrigued
because i'm like how does someone's
brain
get there
to doing the stuff that you do
yeah it's uh i don't know i've always
i've always been a huge fan of jackass
growing up naturally yeah yeah and like
i was never really allowed to watch it
though so like i i grew up in like a
super religious like household really so
like
in indiana right yeah in indiana yeah
yeah super religious family
my uncle's a pastor and like everyone's
like so [ __ ] just so yeah i i couldn't i
wasn't allowed to watch jackass or mtv
at all so i had to like sneak to watch
it use like channel return and oh yeah
and like yeah i mean
it's a huge influence on me so
i gotta i had a video camera at a young
age at like 10 or whatever and
i would try to make like little short
films but i would always end up doing
stunts with my friends yeah because
that's what was always like the funniest
to us yeah wait so how how old are you
i'm 30 now 30 yes yeah i'm 35. so yeah
you're around that that generation yeah
you know what i mean of of that period
of time because yeah all of us remember
you know when that [ __ ] broke out but oh
yeah i mean i think majority of people
were like oh i'll watch it but i can
never do it yeah you were like oh i want
to do it yeah like that looked so fun to
me i was like i have to try this and
then it ended up being really fun i mean
i don't think anyone should do that what
was the first
craziest stunt you did um the first like
thing like when the stun that like okay
the first thing like set it off for me
i was
i laid myself completely on fire
and i just like look i googled like
what's the safest way to set yourself on
fire and it wasn't safe at all still
it was just like what the yeah i i was i
thought it would be so cool because i
had seen like all these videos where
like i've seen a lot of videos where
people put like gas on them yeah yeah
and [ __ ] and i was like there has to be
like a safer way because that's not safe
at all yeah yeah yeah
just putting gas on yeah and then i
found this other way which i'm not gonna
say what it is but like yeah i found
this other way and did that and
filmed it and it was [ __ ] hilarious
because i couldn't put myself out either
like so i just like set myself up i was
like
maybe 16 or like 15 or 16. oh [ __ ] and
just lit myself on fire on like a sand
dune yeah and i'm just rolling down we
had like one cup of water to put me out
yeah that didn't know well the sand
sand helps a little bit but like it is
on fire yeah so i just rolled down a
hill i completely fired my friends are
hitting me with hoodies trying to put me
out
uh it was pretty funny is this video out
there i don't know where it's at now
because either i used to like license
all these videos to this website called
break.com when i was younger it was like
there was like a com
was it like a site for it was a site for
like viral videos and there was also it
was also it was like a competitor of
like e-bombs worlds and [ __ ] oh okay
okay okay so yeah okay yeah and they
like uh
yeah so i had like a bunch that went
viral on like a bunch of different those
video sites yeah
so it was on all those sites but i think
there used to be a version on youtube
but i think it got terminated but it was
from someone else's account yeah uh it
was called like a fat kid burns calories
or something it was pretty funny
[Laughter]
what a name
yes that's [ __ ] insane so that was
the video that set it off for you yeah
it went viral
and [ __ ] you just were like all right
this is it yeah like that was that was
it for me and then i just made like i
made tons of viral videos from there i
got into this whole thing where
um i was like
i would always get hit in the nuts with
different things
and that was like my thing for a while
like one time we dropped like he said
for a while he said for a while yeah you
know
for a while
that was the not everyone wants to do
that and i was like that's my thing like
because i can just stand i don't have to
jump off of anything i can just stand
there and get hit in the nuts with all
these different crazy things and like
that will be my thing and then there's
like other people that were doing that i
had rivals like i had like yeah
but you were the only where you grew up
you were the only dude oh yeah doing
that yeah i was like the only person
doing that like where i live where i
grew up yeah but there were like other
people on the internet from like other
places that were like in other little
like underground stunt crews they would
do like crazy things and we all have
like so sort of like rivals in a way
yeah do you remember i don't know if you
remember this there was like i think
they were like british dudes that had a
similar or they were australian i think
are you talking about uh they had a
similar like had their versions
uh
yes they're from i think they're from
they're finished i think they're oh
they're finished yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah then they have their own show
or something yeah it was just called the
dudes yeah yeah yeah they were dope
they're really dumb they're so gnarly oh
so you know those guys yeah yeah and i
don't know them like personally um i
just seen all their stuff there yeah
they're crazy did you ever think
that you would [ __ ] be
here based off of [ __ ]
i i know you just do you yeah it seems
like you genuinely
enjoy the [ __ ]
i do i mean it's that's a different
[ __ ] rush it is
i never thought that it would take me to
being on jackass
because like that's just like a dream
you know that's just like oh like anyone
that like anyone that does like jackass
style videos like they're the one thing
they've all they always want to do is be
on jackass yeah um and that just doesn't
seem like a reality and then somehow
like i ended up where that happened it
was just insane yeah it was she linked
with stevo
what when was that that was in the
cactus yeah i did that in 20
2017. yeah
this [ __ ]
was on a skateboard he's supposed to
he was on like i don't know some ramp
that they [ __ ] yeah right together we
went to home depot and just put like a
bunch of wood
put plywood down and he's supposed to
[ __ ] clear the cactus well this one
this [ __ ]
flew into the goddamn character straight
into it didn't go
yeah and then they use the rope to get
them out like go to the go to you
luckily we had that rope because we
didn't really know we didn't think about
how to get me out maybe type in zack ass
yeah like cactus cactus yeah
that one yeah
you can fast forward a little bit
you're [ __ ] insane
tony hawk can't be on that one
this is [ __ ]
nice drop in
oh
just didn't lift off
where was this at that was here in l.a
uh it was in l.a i'm from arizona yeah
and we got a lot of [ __ ] cactus and
none of us none of us ever [ __ ] with
cactus like dude cacti i i don't like to
[ __ ] with cactus but i mean i did
another cactus thing in the movie
yeah but yeah like this sucks
but i did it again
oh yeah cause like i mean i know what
it's like to [ __ ]
get cactus out like i mean yeah like you
know just growing up in arizona like
i mean you're gonna come across it you
know because they're just everywhere
yeah like i've been like [ __ ] you
know
stunned by one or whatever like
yeah like you [ __ ]
i mean i don't know anyone that's
[ __ ] jumping into it
that's the first i've ever seen look at
oh my god
yeah it sucks like he pulls that one out
oh dude that one's so deep
as [ __ ]
how oh so so
how long did it take to get all those
out
it took about three months to get all
the needles out like in total
um
because like a bunch of them like were
in there and they like i had a bunch in
there that broke off i tried we tried to
pull out as many as we could right the
right of the jump but then some were
like just stuck under my skin like super
deep and we couldn't get them but i
could feel them
and some were just like stuck in there
to the point where i couldn't pull them
out like they gave me antibiotics so
because i ended up getting a staph
infection from that
they gave me antibiotics and like your
body like starts to reject the needles
at some point and then you can like pull
them out or they'll just come out
randomly
but
like some of them just wouldn't come out
like even i wonder how you guys why i
gave you staff effects i don't know
probably just them being in there yeah
being in like now i know like
immediately if i ever do anything in
cactus now i i just like go to the
doctor and get put on antibiotics
immediately so enough to deal with like
getting some gnarly infection so oh so
before you did the recent
the recent one i you were already on
antibiotics i wasn't already on them i i
had like i was like yeah i set up an
appointment for the doctor though
already yeah so i was like yeah i'm
gonna need to go to the doctor because
it's gonna get infected
it's always how it is usually
this time this last time in the movie
though it was only a month it was like a
month and a half that i still had them
in
mind
yeah
but still yeah but still it sucked
it's like for a good like it takes like
two weeks to really get used to like
having cacti needles in you and like
sitting and moving yeah then you get
used to it and you're just like whatever
like
casey's face
he's just like
it's not like trying to sleep with it
it's so bad oh yeah oh [ __ ] after that
that one was stevo though it was not it
was even earlier because i ended up
getting
like the worst sunburn in my life yeah
like on top of that on top of having the
yeah on top of having them in me i went
to an urgent care and they were more
worried about my sunburn than the cacti
needles really yeah they were like so
freak they were like like this isn't
good like you have they're like because
i was like getting dizzy and like having
like all these like dude it was just
from the infection
do you meditate uh yeah okay i figured i
was like he's gotta do
i started meditating recently
and that's been dope but
i wish i had meditation before that i
know because i was like you have to do
something to train your brain
because like especially for something
like this like
you know
you got to get in like david goggins
mode or something
like you know stay hard and then [ __ ]
just
like before you obviously your heart's
like racing before you do it oh yeah i'm
always nervous before i do something i'm
never just like oh let's just do it i'm
chill like there we go i know yeah yeah
i was like you can't beat yeah sometimes
i'm like freak i'm like it's like
yelling at myself like do it do it you
can do it like it's like [ __ ] has
there
ever been anything you said no to um
yeah i mean there was uh
i'm not a big fan of heights so there's
something with like high also i feel
like fat people and i just don't mix
gravity don't mix it's like
so i i try not to do anything that's
like
too high up i've said no to like one
like something
where i was like supposed to i was
supposed to jump into these box it
wasn't for jackass it was for something
else and i was supposed to uh
do a high fall but i still had my cast
on from my broken leg because i broke my
leg before on the skateboard yeah
i've been following you for a minute
you know i've been following you for a
hot minute so like i've seen
a lot a lot of your stuff i mean let's
take a little break from talking to zac
ass and talk about the dopest kratom in
the game right now happy hippo i just
started using cradium uh helps me with
my brain gets me focused uh before shows
or before my uh podcast or anything like
that um
uh probably one of the best focus
products i think i've used listen i do
still take a little coffee but i found
kratom to be a lot better and it's all
natural super healthy nothing crazy to
it not going to make you have the
jitters or anything like that so visit
happyhippos.com and use promo code thick
boy for 20 off for life use that code as
many times as you want once again
happyhippo herbals.com using promo code
thick boy for 20 off
so then
how did you get linked with mtv
for your uh they're too too stupid to
die so i had a bunch of viral videos
and like they like so i i just had a
viral video after viral video because
before uh i did the thing with stevo
i had this firecracker vest thing yeah
that was
when i jump on the spine ramp and snap
the skateboard and do the nut shot that
really was like the first thing that
like went super viral because i had just
gotten out of jail for like a weed
charge or whatever and like i couldn't
like get it right
i couldn't get like a normal job or
anything it was really hard because i
lived in indiana and weeds like super
illegal there yeah so
i was in jail for like a month
just think about that since alone yeah i
was in jail for weed yeah
it's ridiculous yeah i was in jail for
like a month for weed and then i i get
out and i was like i don't want to work
a normal job anymore also it's going to
be hard to get hired yeah so i was just
like [ __ ] this
i just want to do things that i want to
do something that i love and that's
doing like stun videos and stuff but i
wasn't sure if i was going to be able to
make money from that yeah and then i
started figuring that out and one of the
first viral videos though was the
jumping on the skateboard on the spine
ramp and that went that went pretty
[ __ ] viral and like
uh the next thing was the there's a
bunch of little things in between but
the next really big thing was the
firecracker vest yes
and then i did that thing with stevo um
with the cactus and then in somewhere
between the firecracker vest and the
thing with stevo i got hit up by this
guy that used to uh
he had this production company and used
to be the ceo the ceo of viacom yeah
yeah
yeah which like and he greenlit he
originally greenlit jackass like jersey
shore yeah and like all this other [ __ ]
like uh
so
yeah they were like we want to make a
show with you
and i was like sure yeah that sounds
great that sounds amazing you know let's
do it did you come up with the name oh
yeah yeah i came up with it yeah yeah
good name yeah
too stupid to die
so we did that like so we made a pilot
not sure if it was going to go anywhere
and then we ended up making the show for
mtv yeah yeah that's [ __ ] crazy and
then it did it
yeah because like
i mean but like i mean yeah
most people don't get that [ __ ] far
yeah you know what i mean like the
percentage of [ __ ] people that
actually get their show going yeah is a
[ __ ] small percentage yes it's like
[ __ ] going from college to pro yeah
the percentage is very [ __ ] little
but uh
so like you started to come up with a
[ __ ] game plan to be like all right
this is gonna be the thing that i'm
going to do and this i'm going to make
money off this yeah you just started
attacking
the situation and you you like you
haven't [ __ ]
stopped yeah your instagram you and your
instagram is [ __ ] hilarious thank you
thank you my i listen i watch this video
that you've done
at least like [ __ ] i go back to it all
the [ __ ] you know like you get like
saved yeah yeah oh it's all my [ __ ]
savings yeah it's the [ __ ] uh
the strong one oh my god dude
that [ __ ] video is so ridiculous so
you had to go to reals
yeah i took it off like so i took it off
my main part of my page why did you take
it i know dude okay so yeah i had a no i
was it started this whole [ __ ] like
controversy because i [ __ ] had strong
like so the guy from the leasing our
traps are freaking out because oh yeah
yeah because we made it he freaked the
[ __ ] out because they weren't like i
don't even remember why he was freaking
out but he was pissed but whatever you
know yeah that's whatever and then like
then i i literally just sang a meme from
that video and honestly it doesn't even
make fun of the band it doesn't make fun
of the band but this is where it gets to
like now like
so this is past the trapped part now
we're because i it was that was already
funny that he was pissed and whatever
but uh i oh i found a meme it was that
strong i'll suck you off i start i sang
that as a meme and then ever then all
these people were like claiming that
they wrote that
and like all these people were willing
to die on the hill that i wrote that i
wrote headstrong i'll suck you off and
they're like i wrote that then someone
else was like no i wrote it and all
these people was like just like all
all these people's fan bases are like
things they wrote head strong will suck
you off yeah and like everyone's [ __ ]
like just like trying to [ __ ] like they
it was just insane like i had all these
people like being like dude [ __ ] you you
stole the joke and all that [ __ ] and it
caused all this [ __ ] drama
and then finally like i was like dude
[ __ ] the [ __ ] like yeah i don't even
care anymore people
chill
you didn't you weren't claiming anything
yeah you just made a funny video yeah i
wasn't like oh this is my original song
yeah like also like i was saying that
just like like earlier on in life just
hearing the song headstrong yeah because
it's sort of it's easy to come up like
yeah i make like it's really easy to say
i've said headstrong
like many times in my life let's see
where's it at you see him on like a
four-wheeler yeah that one
there it is yeah it went like super
viral and then i [ __ ] love this song
or this video
yeah i made i'm making uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i watched that video so [ __ ] much
it's hilarious i get i think it's funny
oh yeah people [ __ ] people freaking
out about that yeah we could have made
like a behind the music about yeah i
almost we're gonna make this parody like
like behind the music thing about it but
we didn't because i was like i don't
wanna bring it yeah i don't wanna bring
any more attention so that that's that's
that's what's been cool too is that like
not only have you you know
you know your foundation is the the
stunts and all that stuff but like
you've transitioned into like
doing funny videos yeah yeah as well
which is like pretty dope like
you know have you always been like a
comedy fan or yeah yeah i love comedy
i'm a huge comedy fan uh
yeah like that's always something i
wanted to do is like make like sketch
comedy yeah like i i you know i grew up
like watching snl and different stuff
like that yeah you know so
that's what's uh
being cool to see because
like i i'm trying to think of i tried to
find out somewhere on instagram how long
i've been following you but i think like
yeah
i mean it's been for a [ __ ] minute
since you're
those [ __ ] early videos but yeah like
i i love that um
you're able to like find these other
layers
to yourself
to be able to like like hey i also do
sketches yeah yeah you can't hurt
yourself forever you know yeah that's
the one thing that's the one thing
that's like the most annoying like
because like people would like you do
like a couple crazy things then people
want you to almost kill yourself all the
time yeah and it's just like you can't
do that that's not like possible yeah so
and then it's like you don't want to
keep doing like mediocre stunts like
it's like oh here's a couple here's some
stuff and then it's just not yeah
because
yeah you always have to [ __ ] heighten
this stuff yeah so you know what i mean
like how do you top
skateboarding into a cactus yeah it's
hard it's [ __ ] insane yeah how the
[ __ ] do you do that yeah you you almost
don't like it's just hard dude yeah yeah
so but but um
um
but with these with these sketches like
you have like a crew
uh yeah yeah you like you pretty much
like we uh write a lot of them yeah i
write a lot of them and like my friend
sean writes a lot of them too it's like
sort of like we just like meet up and we
just make stuff on he does all the green
screen videos like that like my friend
sean makes yeah sean barrett
yeah he's [ __ ] sick he's hilarious
he makes like a lot of uh he does music
videos too but uh yeah we just go i go
over to his place and we just like write
stupid [ __ ] and then film stuff in his
like his living room is just a green
screen so he's filming stupid [ __ ] in
there all the time yeah see that's
[ __ ] dope man yeah because yeah when
you think about it no you cannot [ __ ]
yeah
it's just like
it was
you know it's different i was that same
way with cheerleading i was like i can't
cheer forever
you know i'm not i'm not gonna you know
brag world champ
but you know
i'll bring my ring next time for you
casey
but uh
yeah cause you're like what what'd you
say i said okay thanks
[Laughter]
you didn't you didn't want
the the ring and the gold
yeah no i no i i do
did you did you know i did that wait no
i didn't wait okay so yeah how did you
come about to me
because you started following me yeah i
don't even remember like i don't
remember
i don't even because i remember when you
started falling i was like oh dude he
follows me
because i'm like i don't know
yeah i don't know how i got into your
world or whatever i'm not sure either i
think i might have seen like uh
i think i might have seen like a podcast
clip or something okay i don't know i i
watch a lot of podcasts and stuff too
i just started a podcast yeah you did
yeah the fudge yeah what the fudge uh
just started like yeah you're only like
what three episodes in or like i think
it may be i don't even [ __ ] know
honestly
we recorded a bunch but i don't i forgot
exactly how many we've released oh god i
got i got it yeah i think you're only at
three yeah i was doing my deep dives
yeah i was finding out everything you
know
so you big music nerd too um not not as
much wow i like music
like you know someone i'm the worst when
someone's like so what's your favorite
three bands or like what's your top
three whatever i'm like i don't [ __ ]
know well that just [ __ ] it's so
funny because um right now that's what i
took my reference
i do that but
no i got different questions for him
i've been listening to a lot of
turnstile lately though dude i [ __ ]
love
that band and so do i dude i'm obsessed
with that [ __ ] band
i'm obsessed with this [ __ ] band yeah
i i've legit i never really listen to
them before the glow on like stuff like
oh really uh i heard that and then now
i've been listening to everything yeah
so yeah if you go back yet obviously
like the glow on is like
you know really obviously really popped
them but like yeah you know those
earlier stuff you know they were really
finding their
their way and then they really just hit
this thing that like
has like it made them like universal to
like anybody could like listen to that
record and enjoy it like it doesn't have
like you know you don't have to be a
hardcore kid yeah you know
yeah that's always curious like did you
go to shows
yeah i went to i used to go to a lot of
different hardcore shows yeah when i was
younger yeah because i was like
are you from a small town in indiana uh
i'm from near gary indiana um jackson
five yeah yeah mike jackson yeah uh also
the
that [ __ ] if you ever watch ghost
adventures there's the [ __ ] hell
house that zach baggins dude bought oh
it was like yeah there's a whole
documentary about this house that they
bought in gary indiana that's like super
haunted and like kids were like walking
up the walls and [ __ ] and all this crazy
stuff there's all these weird eyewitness
accounts i don't know really he's like
it's funny look at that [ __ ] i don't
okay so i have a couple different like
paranormal stories like things that have
happened to me what uh yeah made on me
okay um oh one of like i feel like my
house is just haunted as a kid
like legit um
one of the weirdest things was like our
our the the shower and our up like in
our the main level of our house
well this is like so [ __ ] weird one
day i was just taking a shower and it's
happened a couple times where like out i
was taking a shower and then i felt like
someone put their hand on my back
and i was like what the [ __ ] like that
scared the [ __ ] out of me i thought it
was just like a breeze like some sort of
shift i don't know what the [ __ ] it was
let's shift the wind i don't know how
there's a shift in there i was like you
know i don't [ __ ] know like there's
no windows in here there's nothing in
here i don't know
so you know that i was just trying to
like write it off like it wasn't that
you know it wasn't like someone touching
my [ __ ] back or whatever then like a
couple
like then like not long after that i
heard my sister scream while she was in
the shower
and she literally like she didn't i was
like what happened and she's like didn't
tell me then she that happened to her
again like a couple weeks later the same
thing yeah yeah and she said she
screamed again in the shower i'm like
what the [ __ ] happened you know and she
was like well i feel like someone put
their hand on my back and i was like
what the [ __ ]
no
and someone else said that to me and
then like i don't know what the [ __ ]
that was all about but that was sort of
weird your folks still have their house
oh no no someone else says that i just
know um
yeah and like my like my grandma always
because i used to go ghost hunting
yeah i would go like with a bunch of
people when i was younger
and uh
that was like after all this like this
was later on after that because that
happened when i was like like the shower
thing happened when i was a kid and then
i think i i stopped using the shower
after that
you do all the insane white people [ __ ]
like already i'm saying like
you know there's there i always tell
people there's layers to white people
there's white people that just go for
the extremes
you're that guy
like my grandma would always say that i
was bringing uh like [ __ ] evil
spirits into the house
she thought you weren't she thought i
was because i was going ghost hunting
and all this stuff and she was also
super religious you know i don't i don't
know if that was really true so when you
go sunday like uh what was the
percentage of like you actually
saw something saw something or like
experience something to not experience
it was like very there were very few
times where something actually happened
like a lot of the times it was like more
like urban exploration you know we have
to go at night yeah we'd go at night and
like pl like we would have to go
definitely at night and it would be like
play like one time we went to this like
abandoned like boys school yeah yeah and
that this place is always sort of scary
it wasn't really like that scary in the
i mean it was scary in there but going
up to it was the scariest part
because there was like it was probably
like a half mile like driveway to get up
there yeah and you had to park in like a
neighborhood and then walk like a
[ __ ] mile to even get there so you
wouldn't get caught
okay yeah and then you had to walk a
place completely abandoned
um i don't really know what happened but
uh like why i was abandoned but it had
been abandoned for years and uh we would
be walking up the driveway to get there
and it would sound like
there was like dogs or something like
like behind you so you would start
running like walking
it would sound like they were like
running up it would sound like they're
running up and so it was scary as [ __ ]
so we would start just like running
because we're like the grass is built up
so we weren't even sure if there were
dogs or coyotes or something you know
so we would just like start running up
to the building
and
every time we would you could like
literally hear like they're like
i guess you would say like collars or
whatever it sounded like there was like
stuff like you know it's like hit if you
hear a dog right here you know it sounds
like yeah and it would always sound like
that when we were when we were walking
up then we'd run and we would hear this
and then it would just stop and we look
behind us there's nothing
and it was like the scariest [ __ ]
thing because no matt it happened every
time we went there
and it all anytime we would stop like
after we were running we it would just
was your town like a crazy town no not
really um because i used to live in when
i cheered in college one of the colleges
i cheered at
in texas
um actually the that netflix docu-series
cheer is about
oh really yeah where i cheered up but
that town
like i don't know if it was just like
some what do they call it urban myth or
something like that yeah it was like one
of the top like satanic towns oh sick in
the country look up athens athens texas
and then we had there's this park
called fuller's park and it was like
this reverend fuller had these monkeys
and the monkeys got out killed him
because he was mean to them
or something crazy that's interesting
and then yeah dude and he uh like i
think they got rid of the [ __ ]
park or whatever
hold on
what does it say type in full at this
texas
fuller's park
but it was one of those things and look
how creepy that [ __ ] looks i think they
tore it down
but like it was one of those
yep
it was like this weird [ __ ] park you
would go in and like
no matter what time of the [ __ ] year
you put your hand over where his grave
was and it'd be cold like it was like
weird [ __ ] like that so i don't know
that's spirits or something like that
and anytime you like you went you would
have to uh
like you couldn't go straight back home
like you had to like
go somewhere else for a little bit yeah
yeah and then [ __ ] yeah then go home
like or whatever because they they
always say like there's people that
could [ __ ] i don't know
also
yeah but also like i'm like one of those
people that are like i don't really know
how i feel about like paranormal [ __ ]
like you've ever [ __ ] to the ouija
board hell no dude okay don't look like
i [ __ ] with a ouija board no i don't
like you
but i appreciate you asking and being
fair and being progressive
you know to really
you know he goes i don't want to rule
out black people
where we're doing ouija boards so i
don't know
so
i have a ouija
story so my sis it was like my sisters
and her friends were like playing with a
ouija board when we were younger
and they were well we weren't allowed to
have that in our house it was at her
friend's house yeah and it was just down
the street and they were like they came
home crying they're like freaking the
[ __ ] out over this ouija board like some
[ __ ] happened they like heard some like
evil laughing or something
and i was like what the [ __ ] you know
didn't know [ __ ] about ouija boards
except for like that shit's evil yeah
you know yeah i was like super christian
at the time too oh you were i was like
i'm this that shit's evil we gotta burn
it
tattoo when you recruit no
yeah
i was born with it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dude that's funny you thought of
a pentagram thing uh so i get a lot of
comments i'm like every once in a while
i'll get comments like you satanist [ __ ]
like really yeah yeah dude people are so
[ __ ] wild like like you don't [ __ ]
know me yeah like the devil isn't even
that
crazy do you like it like you don't know
who i am what does that even mean you
don't know anything about me yeah yeah
you see the [ __ ]
also at the same time don't take those
people [ __ ] seriously oh no yeah
i just think it's funny because like
some people will be like you sold your
soul and now you're in you're in a movie
now is it was it worth it selling your
soul it's like dude what the [ __ ] you
get those kind of comments i guess kind
of comments a lot
whatever illuminati thing like
so
there's this one dude i went to high
school with that's like he's like sure
that i'm in the illuminati really and
like he's like he like tells everyone
i'm like why are you saying this to
everyone how do you like me
it's so it's so funny what i want to
hear the end of that ouija board story
oh yeah yeah yeah sorry i'm sorry i was
going to go back
ouija boy yeah so
back to the ouija board yeah so my
sisters are like crying and i'm like we
have to burn this thing so i'm like
super christian all the time and i you
know they just want to burn everything
christians
so [ __ ] we go and grab the [ __ ]
i go and get the ouija board i put it in
like in a garbage bag and like put it on
my bike and like i don't even touch it
like i had someone else put it in there
and like we took it and like
i take it back to my house we had like
this little fire pit dude i'm trying to
burn this thing for like ever it will
not burn like i'm putting gas on and i'm
putting all this different chin on it
won't [ __ ] burn literally won't burn
and then finally it starts to burn
and when it starts to burn the like the
embers turn into like the shape of a
face
it was so [ __ ] scary dude and then
[ __ ] like
everyone that was around watching it
like freaked the [ __ ] out and they saw
like burning into like the shape of a
face
and i was like i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on like i wish i wouldn't
have done this like are you serious i
was so scared dude i was so [ __ ]
scared and then finally like it just
like dissipated and it was just it was
done with but i looked up like later
uh the like top few things you're not
supposed to do with the ouija board
um number one is burn it
um
number two is like not closing it out
and they definitely didn't close it out
because they like freaked out and ran
away you're supposed to close it out and
then like if you don't close it out
supposedly
anything that you're talking to or
contacting
can can like leave especially if you
burn it because if you burn it anything
that you were talking to
is like is free now pretty much it can
like come out like and
was this before the shower shoulder grab
uh this is uh actually it might be i
don't know dude i think that's who was
grabbing that that might be actually um
that makes sense and that actually
searches
sort of scary songs yeah yeah
scooby-doo over here
scooby-doo
um
i don't have a story about doo but did
you meet him
those [ __ ] kids
[ __ ] scoot like
not scooby-doo
um so yeah like the other thing was like
if you burn like so you can't you
shouldn't burn it you have to close it
out
and like two things can either happen if
you burn a ouija board and and don't
close it out
um you're like one you're like you're
supposed to die instantly or whatever is
supposed to like just follow you around
for the rest of your life
and yeah
[Laughter]
see that's that's the layer of white
people that i'm talking about with that
extreme [ __ ] right there
that's yeah it's following them and [ __ ]
yeah yeah right so that's gonna [ __ ]
you know
but also like like
i don't know like yeah i don't really
like i don't i don't know about that
yeah it's it's like weird because i i
mean like i'm like uh whatever like
i think it's just really interesting you
know yeah it is it is interesting you
know what i mean yeah but like
because like i've watched a couple ghost
hunter episodes and i go
well what the [ __ ] was that like
sometimes
i mean like they're reaching a lot
sometimes yeah he was like did you hear
that he said it yeah he said like i'm
like you heard that like meanwhile he
said a name it's like no he said
yeah
that wasn't that was a crackle in the
microphone bro like nothing happened
exactly especially if you're making a tv
show it's like the producer's like oh
yeah yeah yeah they just say something
yeah maybe you could say something real
quick like yeah it happens you don't
have an episode i don't know and
meanwhile these ghosts they don't sign a
[ __ ] release form they do actually
the ghost there's a sad ghost a second
otherwise it's gonna be blurred out
[Laughter]
there was like a ghost adventure episode
where they like went to
the
the park where like joe exotic had uh
like wherever that was
or whatever that was ridiculous um wait
you're so um you ever been to kentucky
no oh yeah no i've been to kentucky i
just like i don't think i've ever like
stayed in kentucky
they have like a crazy
haunted like house that's been there for
years i think it was on the ghost
hunters oh yeah
it might be called waverly
hills
is it waverly hills
oh yes selling tickets to this [ __ ] oh
they are oh [ __ ]
like
yeah there was this oh there was this
one yeah i don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] at
all because
back to athens or whatever yeah there
was this like abandoned hospital and it
was like i think it was one of the
mental hospital or something yeah i
don't know what the [ __ ] it was but
anyways that [ __ ] was abandoned for
years it's just in the middle of a
neighborhood yeah surrounded by [ __ ]
houses and [ __ ]
you know as soon as i walked in i saw
the pentagrams i was like i ain't doing
this [ __ ] i [ __ ] land
type in
this texas abandoned hospital
you'll see this [ __ ]
abandoned i don't even know if they tore
that hoe down
hit images
it matches
look at that hoe
that [ __ ] right there
yeah so when we lived there they were
scared like me and a couple of my uh
teammates
were like yo let's go to it and i was
like and i was all hype and i was like
yeah let's do it yeah doing it with my
friends there's always like one person
that's sweet
yeah that was me and then all of a
sudden i walk up to that i go
yeah i ain't doing that
i think would they have a picture of it
inside right there
yeah yeah that's that the whole time
yeah i want to do that yeah that's just
scary
gosh hell no
yeah that's see okay
listen fake as [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
because i was like that's not my culture
so you're doing your part now yeah doing
the podcast with the fudge how's that
how's that feel to the pod positive
positive joke i like it yeah i mean
we're figuring it out you know like i'm
like getting more comfortable just like
being a podcast host yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's um
i mean
you know it podcasting is a weird word
because it's so so free range yeah but
there is like a
skill set to it yeah yeah you know what
i mean to make it like to continue to be
interesting and
you know i don't know there's just a lot
[ __ ] to it yeah so when people first
get into it like you feel weird because
you're like
yeah so i i'm sorry
yeah but you're starting to get a solid
flow of it yeah so what you guys did was
you banked episodes
first yeah well it's just like sometimes
we'll get like we haven't really we
banked a couple and then now
we have a couple guest episodes but
we're doing it where it's like we've
been taking a bunch of guest episodes so
it's like every it's like we have an
episode with just vinnie and i and then
it's a guest vinnie and i guess that's
sort of how we're doing it but um
it's funny because like the episodes
with with us just us are doing better
than i guess
yeah and i'm not sure if it's just
interview stuff or if it's just because
like also people could just not care
yeah you know a lot of times like
interviews are like
tough yeah you know what i mean like
because not everybody can be rogan and
[ __ ] just bring literally anybody on
yeah and then it just [ __ ] kills you
know what i mean
like it's um
it's it's tough but like you i think if
you just like have the
consistency
then people will just catch on just
because they they enjoy
yeah you know the host and like it's
like oh why is this host want to talk to
this person i think that it eventually
gets to that you know like yeah i mean
like you i'll even be honest with myself
like you know some of my episodes do
great i have all guests yeah yeah yeah
some will do great some of them don't
some of you you know like it just all
varies and it's uh but i think as long
as you just keep the consistency i think
i don't know
yeah you know i'm no [ __ ] guru yeah
to this [ __ ] you know
yeah most of uh most everything that
i've done like it's just like as long as
you keep consistent like things end up
working out oh yeah you could easily hit
your nuts yeah
and look where he's at look where we're
going
this is this you know flip we're
flipping off everybody
back in uh what is it called what music
town
uh over in indiana over indiana yeah
they didn't believe in this one
they didn't believe he could get hit in
the nuts 50 000 times before he [ __ ]
landed
so wait where did you move to los
angeles uh in 2018 okay okay
oh when you started doing the the show
for mtv yeah it was like right out it
was like we had finished in like 20
we had finished like late 2017 filming
that yeah and then i moved to l.a like
immediately following yeah yeah so wait
what was your last job um
good question um
i mean i've been working strictly
entertainment stuff since that's what
i'm saying
um
i worked at well before i went to jail i
worked at walmart
um i worked at walmart for like oh like
like three years
i worked at walmart for like three years
and uh like first i was like an unloader
just like unloading trucks dude i did
that yeah but i didn't like the last
three years
two weeks i was back there for i did
that for like way longer than i thought
i was going to yo can i can i say
something i wonder if you felt this you
know like you have those shift meetings
yeah yeah
do they always feel
very cult-like dude it's so weird didn't
it feel weird yeah it's [ __ ] weird
and they do this like weird chant at the
end yeah
dude i [ __ ] forgot about that oh my
god yeah yeah you do like this chant at
the end or like all right who's going to
leave it today yeah one person you're
and i'm sitting here back here like
like it's so [ __ ] weird they're like
one more thing
it's so crazy
yeah walmart walmart was insane yeah i
did the unloader stuff too it was like
the over like the
like 4 p.m to like i think midnight or
something yeah yeah shift or whatever
and then you kind of stop you know
stalking that you know some of the stuff
yeah
man i hated that job i [ __ ] hated it
i think it lasts like two or three weeks
yeah i did that and then they they
switched me to electron i got
i got transferred out to electronics
photo department yeah and that was so
much better but then i was like dealing
where i was living because i was living
near fort wayne at the time um
in like close to ohio and [ __ ] and there
was like an amish community where we
were living yeah yeah and
when i worked in the electronics
department the amish people because
they're not supposed to use phones and
[ __ ] they would like and they they still
do
they just lie about it and like [ __ ] it
and like it's whatever i don't i don't
give a [ __ ] they use them but it's just
funny it's just funny like they if they
don't go up to the like cell phone store
part in the in the front of walmart they
would come back to me and be like can
you set up this phone for me like they
would like be like really sneaky about
it oh because yeah they're not supposed
to be using they don't want to be like
up in the front of the store being seen
yeah or they'd be like do you have a
phone case for this and they'd show me
their phone really quick they're not
supposed to use like any cell phones
yeah yeah or like electronics sort of in
general i don't i don't know i think
that the rules have changed over the
years a little bit i would hope so like
well like let yourself evolve like a
phone's not gonna [ __ ] yeah
i mean if a phone [ __ ] makes you go
crazy then well i mean which they do
they do they make me
yeah yeah yeah you're right you're right
you're right
fair yeah
you know what how much you win that one
phones are [ __ ] nuts but yeah like
yeah i worked at walmart for like you
know too long and then yeah and it's
just been entertaining since yeah pretty
much that's [ __ ] dope yeah
i also okay i want to i need to take
that back actually so aft like after i
got out of jail i did work at taco bell
for a little bit you're a [ __ ]
champion um then i quit because i yeah i
quit for yeah working at all the best
places
[ __ ] everybody man
we got [ __ ] zacharias you know i knew
your name was zach rice did you
does anyone call you that uh yeah i
prefer i prefer like being called no i
don't remember
but that would be so funny like i was
one of those people i prefer being
called by my full name my uh it's not
zack yeah
i don't like being called zachary though
cause it's like i'm not zachary
zachary sounds like you're five yeah
yeah yeah
you're wearing a backwards cap
[ __ ] spinny wheel
exactly
well usually i do [ __ ] wrap it
questions and those are the [ __ ] wrap
that's funny um
but i mean i gotta switch them up okay
favorite answer though i got it favorite
stunt you've ever done favorite stunt
i've ever done um
i would have to say
like probably
into stupid the evil knievel troop you
think i did the motorcycle jump uh the
i was just like i was on like a little
mini bike yeah
yeah yeah that was your favorite one
yeah it was one of my favorite like i
mean also like any like the the cactus
jump with stevo is amazing
you know
i i loved like that was dope doing that
because i was just such a cool
experience i was one of the first times
i met stevo well that was the first time
i met stevo i was doing and it was in
doing that
yeah and wait so wait how did you he saw
your video or something yeah so i i had
a bunch of viral videos and then
some of the this page that was sharing
my videos was uh this company called xyz
clothing and that was originally his uh
yeah he was sponsored by them they sent
me much stuff and i'm wearing xyz stuff
and everything i do and he saw that was
like what the [ __ ]
and then
he that was originally they're like who
he reached out to them they're like who
is this guy
and
he was they told they're like oh that's
zach it's our boy and then that's time
that i'm meeting stevo's through xyz so
did you have to audition for jackass um
no not i mean well like they knew that i
i would do gnarly [ __ ] and like they uh
they like hit me up and they're like
okay at first they told me they weren't
even like they didn't say we're making a
movie so we're making a jackass 20th
anniversary special
and i get there
and i end up being in this meeting with
knoxville and tremaine and i'm pitching
them a bunch of ideas
and they're like oh you know they loved
everything went great and then they're
like okay uh we're gonna do like this
test we're gonna do like this test shoot
we'll do a couple stunts yeah in like in
a couple months we ended up doing that
and then but before that they're like
okay we're actually making a movie it's
this isn't for it's like we're testing
out with these new people we did a a
pre-shoot where we tested out the new
people to see if it would actually work
yeah having new people with the old cast
and like you know it did it worked out
pretty well yeah there's a few people
that didn't i know rachel yeah yeah
rachel i was just talking to her on the
phone before i came in here oh you were
yeah yeah yeah so where do you guys
share birthday yeah we shared a birthday
same age same birthday yeah yeah
all right uh worst
injury worst injury
um breaking my legs the skateboard yeah
that was definitely the worst oh my god
it's such a narcissist yeah so watch it
on your own casey viewers
it's so funny though at the end where
like i was just like
calling i get i'm like freaking the [ __ ]
out then i'm like i'll call i'm like
call 9-1-1 please
like you do you feel that like shock
feeling like that like like that and
feeling where you're just like i'm in
[ __ ] pain and it just was it your
femur oh no it was my it was tip
it broke like in a couple different
spots though it wasn't just like a clean
like a cross it was like a cross in the
top and like it was like it was like two
different spots it was [ __ ] yeah
it was bad
then they uh it was also funny because i
was like really trying to learn how to
skate at that time
and this dude that uh
like i like learned how to drop in i
could do like a rock to fakie and [ __ ]
like that and then i tried to do that
rolling grind when i couldn't ollie out
of it which was really dumb
and but no one thinks they're gonna
break their leg from a [ __ ] one foot
drop you know whenever i think about
that video specifically i feel this like
thing in my this tingle
in my nuts oh you know you know like
we're just like you see it it cringes
and i don't know why for me
other people have may have different
spots where it happens for them it's
always my nuts yeah it's always where
i'm like
yeah you know
same um
and then oh yeah funny thing though like
this guy
right after i broke my leg he's like i
know exactly what you did wrong man and
i'm just like dude i don't give a [ __ ]
right now like i don't know hey i just
want to reach out to you and let you
know i know what you did wrong i knew
exactly what you did wrong like on the
spot he was like telling me and i'm like
yeah dude like i don't really care right
now yeah yeah
all right favorite stunt from new
jackass fair that i did or just that
anyone did or just yeah yeah um
hmm from the new jackass yeah you know
what let's do one that one that you
you liked okay
you weren't in i'm like jealous of this
bit it's so good like the one where
preston
is uh
getting the his balls punched
by that little i don't want to say like
a little bit but like but yeah like
preston's getting his balls punched and
it's hilarious and you wanted to do that
i wish i would have came up with that
that's amazing
yeah
okay so now i don't know if this part is
tough but i always like to do a
soundtrack for each of my episodes yeah
uh like basically like a playlist that i
go back and forth with with uh we do
like 10 to you know 10 songs or whatever
yeah it usually just fits the vibe of um
the episode with you
so i'll go first
um
since we mentioned them
yeah i'll go turn style they spell it
different
yeah
uh s-t-i-l-e
yep i'll do don't play
all right
um
hmm
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
don't play
this is any song that i think yeah yeah
um
hmm
let me leave you no go to your phone do
whatever yeah whatever you got to do
i got something based off your pentagram
too yeah okay sick
i like how they think you're a satan
worshipper yeah it's so funny it's like
it's like
yeah i know um
i'm gonna do scream by misfits okay good
one yeah
i'll do uh
i gotta go like what a death metal song
uh
or norwegian black metal
uh let's do d aside
[Laughter]
oh you don't know
casey struggles with spelling actually i
don't know d e
d is side
ah no d you ain't d
d aside is it d i
now
see all right this is only [ __ ]
hold on
let me find it casey
oh yeah so d-e-i
c-e-i-d
and what do you side song should i do
for you
your pentagram
to your side
um
there's a song called bible bashers
pastors
he aside that's that's for your
pentagram
i think i've heard i think i might i
might have actually heard that
before i think stevo's a fan
yeah he wears his shirts and [ __ ] yeah
um
one next
you filming me meatball
are you taking pictures of me
um
here i'm the worst of them
this guy really does not listen to me
i listen to music all the time but i
listen to like emo [ __ ] all the time
throw it out there yeah uh yeah we can
emo what the [ __ ] up uh i like emo stuff
too
here let me see
this isn't emo song but uh feel the
pressure by drain oh drains yeah trains
i've listened to that a lot yeah yeah
they're uh they're newer band they're
pretty dope
um
if we're going emo
i'll do story so far
i love the story so far and i'll do
um
it's called out of it
since we're doing emo
um
this has nothing to do with this
here
a part of me my neck deep actually okay
yeah yeah
oh
i was like singing that in venice the
other day like oh really my friend was
just playing guitar and we were walking
around
and were you filming it we know we
weren't actually we're just [ __ ]
around oh you just yeah
i
i've been making i'm making a comedy
album actually too oh you are yeah i've
been like making like ever since like
like oh you didn't write that song like
i started writing comedy song like i
wrote one um it was making fun of
yeah
a jumper my third eye blind yeah it's
like a dick sucking version of that
i can't wait to hear it yeah i'll show
you after this section oh you got it
i'll do newfound glory
um
understatement
never thought you'd see diaside and
newfound glory in the same playlist
[Laughter]
how many is that casey
seven
um
[Music]
let's do um
act naturally buck owens
just do it
come on buck owen stop playing
and then
man
what do i want to do
i'll do another turnstile song
uh
uh mystery
history is good yeah do you have you
seen them live no i haven't yet i want
you really bad same
all right uh one more we'll have you
close it off
okay um i'm doing another durian stuff
oh yeah yeah go ahead go ahead go ahead
um
i would say
it's between
fly again
um i'm not sure if i should fly again or
if i should do
um
holiday ooh that's a good one how do you
holiday
i like how casey wrote it
all right perfect yeah uh any anything
you want to promote push out there uh
yeah just uh go check out uh my podcast
what the fudge which is on my youtube
channel zackass and what the fudge
podcast is on all uh streaming platforms
so go check it out yep yeah and just
follow me on it follow me on instagram
go see jackass forever in theaters while
it's still there yeah yeah this guy's
doing a damn thing yeah follow his
instagram he posts a lot of [ __ ]
great funny stuff i'm also doing
stand-up now somewhat sorry okay cut out
yeah
i love how you you just go for it i i
did the comedy store um yeah the jam of
the van yeah i'm not jumping in there i
did jamming
yeah
i love that dude he's a great [ __ ]
guy he's great yeah and if uh kansas
city i'll see you this weekend uh friday
and saturday february 25th and 26th at
the comedy club of kansas city then
march 10th through the 12th springfield
missouri you're up after that at the
blue room comedy club april 8th and
april 9th salt lake city wise guys
comedy club and then may 12th hometown
stand up live
boom dude thanks for coming on thanks
for doing this thanks for having me i'm
glad i'm glad we got to [ __ ]
officially yeah meet each other bro
support zack ass man all right thank you
bye
you